is kicking off his 2023 artist Showcase
with a special three-month exhibition
and it's going to be surreal here to
tell us more is surrealist artist Chris
Elliman welcome to the show thank you
for having me before we get into this
artwork which is stunning you made the
made in Vegas 2022 list that's a big
accomplishment what was that like for
you it was incredibly challenging I
didn't know where to put my efforts but
I knew uh if I just got the art in front
of everyone they'd figure out who should
win and that manage you right there okay
how would you describe your surrealism
someone that's not in the art world what
is the art of surrealism surrealism is
trying to be realism of the mind so it's
like a dream but you're trying to base
it in reality which we see your artwork
and now I see that now to me this looks
like you go to bed at night and this is
you wake up this is on your mind you got
Nirvana you got lines and you just put
it onto canvas yes just like that just
like is that easy how are you using a
brush airbrush how do you do it this is
airbrush this is all spray the originals
are much bigger but uh airbrush is so
soft that if you don't work bigger it
tends to get a little too loose for many
eyeballs I mean the work you do it's
it's stunning how long does it take you
to to do one of these pieces each piece
is about six weeks I kind of run out of
canvas
at six weeks as you can see I kind of
fill every corner my Corners are
actually my specialty because it's where
people try and leave the page you bring
them back that is uh looking at it right
here now you look at that you look at
your artwork do you see something you
want to change or once you're done are
you done
I'm all about design like the blueprint
is everything if I don't see it in the
sketch in the drawing then I don't know
where I'm going so as soon as I see the
drawing I see it finished now you have
you have a lot of fans out there and
you're also doing something special with
your fans over the next couple months
are there special engagements where
you'll do meet and greets yes uh there's
uh Friday the 27th as a private
collector meeting and they get to see
all the art get to talk to me and
describe I get to describe it and then
the 28th at uh two to four is a live
paint to where they get to see me
actually do your magic create them right
in front of them and there's Picasso
it's hanging up in there what's that
like to be in the same room same
building as a Picasso for you as an
artist it's awe-inspiring like Picasso I
didn't get when I was a young artist now
I get it so I was lucky enough to get
that aha moment with Picasso because a
lot of people don't understand them but
uh thankfully I do but it's amazing to
hang I love this to him Chris thank you
so much for being here really appreciate
it and then your artwork will be on
display for the next three months